foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
did you think she was a Democrat foreign
[Music]
I mean committed you know to the
Democratic party did you believe that I
mean maybe at one point
you might believe that Kirsten Cinema
was dedicated to the Democratic party
let's talk about our democracy and the
Democratic caucus sorry about that
running late this morning
I was I had a cup of coffee and I had it
on the I had to go get in sorry
we're here in Kirsten Cinema is now an
independent Republican I mean
independent
is she is she an independent
or has she been manipulated
by Mitch McConnell
and big money
and Power
you know it's hard to tell sometimes
in a deliberative body like the Senate
but don't you get the feeling that
it's all just attention [ __ ] type stuff
I believe that's what it is
if you're standing around going whoa she
switched parties
now right after Warnock won and there's
51 Senators caucusing with the Democrats
because really truly there's not 51
Democrats Angus King and Bernie Sanders
aren't Democrats
they're Independence that's why Bernie
Sanders never could win and he wasn't
ever going to win a primary in the
Democratic party Bernie Sanders was
never ever going to win a primary
that be the nominee of the democratic
party because he's not a Democrat he
caucuses with the Democrats he votes
with the Democrats
I believe Bernie Sanders agrees on most
issues with the Democrats that's why he
caucuses with him in the Senate
but he's not a Democratic party member
I mean he is while he's trying to become
the nominee
but when he's not becoming the nominee
he isn't and that's the reality
I mean I I'll upset the Bernie Bros if
they're still out there
but he's not a Democrat he wasn't a
Democrat he was seeking a ticket which
he was not a member of that party
so the question remains Kirsten Cinema
was she ever really a member of the
democratic party I I think at one point
but I think Mitch McConnell convinced
her that she wasn't
quite a member of the democratic party
she was just part of the caucus
and in this moment where Democrats take
the majority in the Senate presumably
with 51 in their caucus as opposed to
50.
one would
presume maybe that's the reason why
Senator Cinema is seeking attention
is because
when Herschel Walker lost big time
and Senator Warnock won
all of Kirsten Cinema imaginary power
melted away
all of it
because we you know we can talk about
Joe manchin as well
but it seems as if the entire time the
problem inside the Senate
that the Biden Administration and the
Democratic party had may have not been
Mansion as much as it was Kirsten Cinema
I mean you don't see Joe manchin going
to be an independent
hmm
I want something to consider you know
the people that are really probably
[ __ ] pissed off more than anybody
that Kirsten Cinema has now left the
Democratic party to become an
independent independent
okay
is the people who work to get her
elected as a Democratic candidate
and that [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] has the
goal to tell Jake Tapper that the what
the people of Arizona want they told you
what the [ __ ] they wanted that's they
wanted a Democratic senator
a member of the democratic party a
Democrat to be the senator of Arizona
and the people who worked for her
campaign volunteered holy [ __ ] you got
to imagine those people are super
[ __ ] pissed
and maybe that's the story here is
there's no [ __ ] way in eight months
nine months when the race heats up here
for 2024 for those Senate seats
and we start to see her primary
challenges emerge
that there's no [ __ ] way she'll even
be able to collect up enough [ __ ]
small donations and volunteers to even
mount
a challenge to a primary
who in the [ __ ] who who supported her
and volunteered for her wouldn't walk to
another campaign there's probably not
[ __ ] many of them and that's the talk
this morning oh Kirsten said I'm just
gonna break the vote in Arizona if she
was going to break the air vote in
Arizona she would remain in the
Democratic party folks
she's not gonna break the vote in
Arizona because she's not going to be
the Democratic nominee she cannot she
she will not be the she would have not
been
she won't be now she will not have she
would have not have been
the nominee for the Democratic party for
that senate seat in Arizona and she's
the incumbent she would have lost her
primary
do you know how she knows this
Kirsten Cinema isn't [ __ ] dumb I
don't think she's dumb I mean
she's a little naive about her power
that she wants to possess here
but she's not dumb
and she is she has seen the results in
her state
when it's coupled with crazy
and Arizona
regardless of party Democrat Republican
they're not going to do the whole
[ __ ] crazy thing they're just not
going to play the crazy game
you don't give a [ __ ] if it's Democrats
or Republicans
they're just not gonna play that
[ __ ]
and gen Z showed up in Arizona and
that's probably another thing Weighing
on Senator Cinema's mind
is how in the [ __ ]
am I gonna win these [ __ ] back
because her plan and over the next two
years
is to play this seesaw with her
quote-unquote power now I ultimately
believe that Cinema will caucus
with the Democrats
and for no other reason that the the
people of Arizona selected a Democrat a
democratic
a member of the Democratic Party
to be their senator
so
she's probably going to caucus with the
Democrats and that's where her power
lies anyways
I mean think about it if she walks and
caucuses with the Republicans which is a
possibility you know it's not out of the
realm of possibility but if she does
that she has no power none she's not the
51st senator
but now she holds some sort of card and
Power
[ __ ] her [ __ ] her
I'm telling you
now now is the time to dunk Kirsten
Cinema in the trash bin of history of
senators [ __ ] her
she's I I mean she's auditioning to be a
contributor to Tucker Carlson's show
and a guest host like Tulsi gabbard
but I mean money does funny things to
people right it does a lot of funny
things to people especially when you
couple money with an imaginary [ __ ]
power you think you have over people
and when people in power
pretend like you have this imaginary
power over people
in other words she thinks she controls
the Senate
that's what she believes here
that she controls part of the Senate
I think she's barking up the wrong tree
what do you think I actually don't
believe this has much effect on anything
I just I I honestly believe this is only
attention seeking she did a [ __ ]
video on it it's really dumb this is not
like this has never happened before Joe
Lieberman did this and Joe Lieberman was
on the [ __ ] ticket in 2000 the top
ticket
so this is not like it's never been done
before she's not doing anything
interesting or [ __ ] unique here
it's not like she went to be a
republican if she if she is she she was
already that before she decided to
officially register as an independent
whatever the [ __ ] that means the only
real independent I see in the United
States Senate is Angus King
Angus King truly is an independent if
you ever listen to him watched him work
uh ask questions and com in committee
meetings any interviews he truly is the
independent senator
Bernie Sanders is a Democratic Socialist
he's just registered as an independent
he's not a Democrat he's not a member of
the democratic party the only time he
was is when he was trying to take the
ticket which that was the rub
it's why the Democratic party didn't
really want Bernie Sanders in 16 or 20.
because he wasn't part of the democratic
party only when it suited him and I'm
not knocking Sanders I mean Sanders has
a lot of sway
not anymore
that's what happens to Losers
you know that right that's what happens
to losers Texas ball was talking about
this you know last week I believe or the
week before about better O'Rourke as
much as a star is better O'Rourke is
he's a loser and that's that is you J in
politics
it's just how it works
and that's how it should be treated and
the reason why is because if you
continue if you continue in politics
to try to elevate someone who is
continually lost elections you end up
like the Republican party where they're
at now lost just [ __ ] lost out in
nowhere land supporting a [ __ ]
Criminal
speaking of criminal news
as lawyers are apparently looks like
they're going to be held in contempt
which you know it's the fine
you know it's not it's not anything
serious
but the most significant thing is that
Grandpa poopy pants do not seek an
appeal now he's absolutely losing his
mind over on his fraud social uh Network
whatever the hell it is over there he's
posting over there losing his [ __ ]
mind saying all kinds of [ __ ] that
isn't true that his lawyers are not
making arguments in the court of law and
the reason why is because what we see
with Rudy Giuliani when you make
arguments like that you lose your
[ __ ] law license
so they can't make those arguments
doj is at the special Master is now
officially done
because he didn't he did not seek an
appeal
and the reason why is because they
didn't have a good [ __ ] argument
they didn't have a good argument
and it's likely I think it's likely that
he wanted his attorneys to go [ __ ]
sell some [ __ ] to the Supreme Court
and they weren't willing to do it and
told him to [ __ ] off
when your attorneys of your attorneys of
your attorneys have to get attorneys and
those attorneys have to get attorneys
you know there's a [ __ ] Breaking
Point somewhere
foreign
but he did not seek an appeal to the
Supreme Court to the special Master
which basically hands over the entirety
of the evidence to doj and the FBI
and Jack Smith
huh
so we'll see if we get a Christmas gift
or not
maybe a New Year's party we can
celebrate you know for some indictments
I don't know just saying Jack Smith
seems to be not not
not wasting any time he was working on
Thanksgiving even the day of
Thanksgiving
eating turkey
getting ready to indict a turkey
so we'll see we'll see
but this is all from uh Kirsten Cinema
attention seeking
it's what that's what she's doing this
morning what she's going to continue to
do over the weekend as they interview
her
the next week we'll find out that it's
the same [ __ ] thing she's going to
caucus with the Democrats
and she's just doing this so she doesn't
lose a primary
that's what she's doing
she does not want to lose a primary and
the main thing is she doesn't want to
show how
publicly
how much support she has lost
by the decisions she's made as a senator
listen this is a democratic
constitutional republic
and in that system of democracy
we the people elect our Representatives
rather those are state
officials
yeah you know County Commission mayor
School Board
State officials like state
representatives state senators Governors
attorney generals
or it's National officials
a member of the House of Representatives
a senator a president
they are there to represent us
and the Mandate comes from us their term
limits come from us
Kirsten Cinema's term is over she is
going to term limit out I guarantee you
the people of Arizona will damn sure
make a hell of it make sure of that
oh well she's going to run as an
independent and she's going to siphon
off those with what
Arizona
has sent a clear message in this last
election that they are not going to put
up with crazy now the Republican party
in Arizona oh they're all on board ah
[ __ ] crazy train is here
[ __ ]
how do you think they produce Blake
Masters in Kerry Lake
and continue to push this craziness
the Republican party in Arizona is
absolutely infiltrated with Q Anon nut
jobs
and it's not going to change tomorrow
so do you think
for the 2024 race that
that somehow they're gonna put up a
non-crazy person get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
they're not gonna put up a non-crazy
person
they're not
they just won't
a crazy person will be
the Republican nominee it'll be a whack
job a q an honor probably
insurrectionist election denier 100 that
party in Arizona is broken
why do you think she's running as an
independent she couldn't even get even
if Kirsten Cinema ran as a republican
she's not that crazy
[ __ ] no
but she's position positioning herself
for power in the senate for the
remainder of the time and her term limit
because folks I I can't stand when
people talk about [ __ ] term limits
for and for house reps and Senators [ __ ]
that [ __ ] we are their term limit God
damn it we decide it is us
we do not have to give incumbents
the benefit of the doubt and give them
our vote if they are not doing the job
and there is someone better we can turn
them out
in a primary or in a general election
either one
but I know for damn sure that the
volunteers
in Arizona who who who pulled Kirsten
Cinema over the line as a matter of fact
there is no way that she would be a
senator
without her Army of volunteers that she
had in Arizona
no way those people work super hard to
get that Senator elected and if you
think if you think
that that that army of of volunteers
who pulled Kirsten Cinema over the line
to win that election if you think for a
minute
that those people aren't [ __ ] pissed
this morning in Arizona that she has
turned she has turned their back on them
they worked hard for it for a member of
the Democratic Party
to be the senator I talked about
affiliation the other day you remember
this talk about affiliation and that's
what gets in the [ __ ] minds
of people
it's third party endorsement right
well my dad my daddy was a Republican
my mama was a Republican
I vote a republican my whole life
so they vote Republican doesn't matter
and we give a [ __ ] even if it's a [ __ ]
box like Trump they'll vote for him yeah
sure why not [ __ ] them
even in Missouri I gave you the example
where people were voting for The
referendum to decriminalize marijuana
recreationally and then they voted for
Eric Schmidt a republican attorney
general who who is vehemently opposed to
marijuana being legalized recreationally
doesn't make any sense but it's not
supposed to make sense
it's not supposed to and if you believe
that's it and this is what pisses me off
about [ __ ] liberals right I'm a
liberal but this is what really pisses
me off about liberals in general okay
because I got a lot of beef with
liberals as much as I do with
conservatives it's one thing that really
[ __ ] pisses me off
is they think that the Human Condition
doesn't exist inside the Democratic
party I have this problem all the time
even inside the show here right
because because I get this a lot I I get
a comment saying this show sounds like a
right-wing talk talk show yeah it's
supposed to
that's how it's supposed to sound
the human conditions exist inside people
regardless of your ideology folks people
do not want to be do not want to be
talked to like they're [ __ ] dumb
they don't trust me that's why I talk to
them like they're [ __ ] dumb
they they don't want [ __ ] piles of
facts they don't want to be they don't
want you to treat them like you're lower
because they're Elite they don't
it doesn't matter what where on the
political Spectrum you fall
okay they just don't
and they don't they don't want to have
to [ __ ] listen to you talk about you
know some kind of [ __ ] paper
that was put into a report somewhere
with all these statistics they don't
they [ __ ] don't I don't care if
they're [ __ ] liberal conservative
it's The Human Condition folks
and The Human Condition is going to bury
Kirsten Cinema in Arizona with her
support
because if you believe that those those
people who help volunteer
for Kirsten Cinema believe that their
allegiance was to her her and their
loyalty is to her you're [ __ ]
dreaming
their loyalty is to a certain set of
principles and right now in this country
especially in Arizona there's only one
party that has any kind of any kind of
[ __ ] principles towards democracy
Jesus Christ you have one party out
there telling people even if you vote
for the other [ __ ] person we're going
to try to overturn your vote your vote
doesn't matter because we want to win
that's literally what the Republican
party in Cary lake is saying in Arizona
they're still even after being certified
oh it's we're in the end zone now no
you're not you're done dummy you didn't
[ __ ] win not only did you not win
they certified the vote it's official
you [ __ ] idiot where are you gonna
have an insurrection
for the [ __ ] for the [ __ ]
governorship of Arizona
this is really [ __ ] delusional stupid
[ __ ] but that's the point
is it's all based on affiliation it's
all based on third-party endorsement the
reason why the party in [ __ ] Arizona
is so goddamn crazy and they can only
get the crazies to vote for Carrie Lake
and Blake Masters is because they
control the party
that's why
and when the crazies have a hold of
something
The Crazies follow
foreign but it's really easy with
affiliation oh well Carey lake is a
republican Blake Masters is a republic
they may be crazy they may be crazy it
takes a lot to break that cycle
now Cary lake is a lot a lot of crazy
Blake Masters a lot of [ __ ] delusion
a lot of [ __ ] white supremacy
it's able to break a lot of that [ __ ]
affiliation and third party endorsement
it's it has the ability to do that
so Kirsten Cinema turning her back on
her [ __ ] campaign volunteers by
switching parties I believe is enough to
break that affiliation with her and stay
with their affiliation with the
Democratic party and I guarantee you I
guarantee you there will be a candidate
who will be way [ __ ] better in 2024
for that [ __ ] seat than Kirsten
Cinema ever dreamed of after what she's
done the last two [ __ ] years
and what you'll do the next two years
and those those those candidates will
start to emerge late next summer early
fall we will see
What Becomes of the democratic party the
primary race for the senate seat in
Arizona and we should all be excited
about it
and the reason why you should be excited
about it
is because if we can get someone
who isn't [ __ ] enamored by corporate
money and corporate donors to their
campaign who isn't [ __ ] hypnotized by
Mitch McConnell
and Republican leadership to be
bipartisan
[ __ ] out of here with that nonsense why
in the [ __ ] would we want to be
bipartisan with a bunch of goddamn
Traders
what the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here
we aren't gonna be bipartisan with a
bunch of goddamn traders who don't want
a democracy get the hell out of here
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] you can kiss
my [ __ ] ass
and Kirsten Cinema took the message
our message that we don't want her in
the Democratic party if she's gonna do
that [ __ ] I don't want her in the
Democratic party if she's going to do
that [ __ ] to you do you want her to be a
senator
the Democratic senator from Arizona
she's gonna [ __ ] go lick Mitch
McConnell's old wrinkly balls
every half a second every time the
American people need to have their
[ __ ] rights protected [ __ ] that [ __ ]
she could kiss my ass and anyone else's
ass [ __ ] her good I'm glad you're an
independent Pearson Cinema it's about
time you [ __ ] off
everyone stick around we got shitless
Roundup before bonehead of the week it's
Friday bone of the week in the second
hour we'll be right back right after
these messages
we'll be right back
mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Friday Friday Friday what are you doing
this weekend
ready for the holiday season
putting up your Christmas tree I don't
know wrapping gifts
[Music]
are you trying not to participate in the
holidays
you're gonna go see your Q Anon family
members this this Christmas holiday this
holiday season you know you can hang out
with them on New Year's get drunk with
them I get wasted yeah why not wasted
with these q and honors tell them how
you really feel
that's how it works you know your
inhibitions go away when you start you
know having a little bit of alcohol
maybe maybe a little bit of recreational
marijuana depending on which state you
live in and which laws have been passed
already or not maybe it's medical
marijuana maybe you need a medical
marijuana and certificate the one thing
you should do with your relatives is
really explain to them
whether they're Qing on or not
especially you know your conservative
Aunt Vicki Hartzler and how [ __ ]
ridiculous it is that she cries on the
floor of the house yesterday we watched
as Vicki hansler she and she's actually
my rep in Missouri she's crying on the
health floor because she just so upset
that gay people get the Liberty to marry
each other
it's so dangerous listen
I said this yesterday but Vicki Hartzler
you act like
you act like gay people just started
existing you people really are [ __ ]
dumb a danger what are you talking about
we've had we've had lgbtq people in in
our existence since Humanity started
dummy
this is not a new thing
this just didn't get invented people
really are [ __ ] snowflakes
for crying out loud and and it's even
leaking into the whole Britain Greiner
story I told you it would they're like
oh this is all about wokism because
she's gay
I told you the reason why they hate the
reason that the hate that Brittany
Greiner came home as opposed to the two
white dudes is because she is a gay
black woman they [ __ ] hate it oh it's
all about wokism
you you people make everything about
wokism everything just like you're a
Super Hyper focused on everyone's
genitalia including including the
president's son and where you can post
his pictures or not which I'm sure we're
going to go through today with that the
Twitter files 2.0 or whatever the hell
it was I don't know and Jesus Christ
it's just getting dumber and dumber and
dumber
just [ __ ] dumb
when are we gonna get out of this cycle
I'm having to put up with these [ __ ]
idiots
I'm serious
I mean we have to what are we gonna do
and they're bitching because no one is
talking about the Twitter 2.0 on Fox
News they're like there was zero minutes
on on on on on other news stations
talking about the Twitter files yeah
because it's
it's nonsense
what you're reporting is [ __ ] that
everyone already knows you can't post
non-consensual nude photos on Twitter it
breaks their terms of service and you
anyone can report these things even the
Biden campaign can report [ __ ] tweets
that break terms of service and then
like oh well there's internal tools yeah
so
they were there before ah Shadow Banning
as if no one knew that shadow Banning
exists
this is really stupid and then
conservatives are like oh we were we
were we were being targeted which now we
find out they were getting special
treatment really because they're so
they're such [ __ ] racist and bigots
that Twitter had to be really careful
about those accounts
to make sure that they gave them special
treatment it's [ __ ] really stupid
[ __ ] but you know that's where we live
Kirsten Cinema is an independent
and Donald Trump was the greatest
president of all time yeah give me a
[ __ ] break
give me a [ __ ] break
back to the Brittany Greiner story real
quick real quick for all you [ __ ]
hate Watchers out there
if if this Wayland [ __ ] this
Marine right
if if Donald Trump really wanted that
[ __ ] home why didn't he do it
when he was president huh why didn't he
just call up his old butt buddy Putin
and say hey hey vladdy Daddy
will you send me my Marine home he
didn't
he didn't
he didn't
so stop saying that stupid [ __ ] and
threads you dumb [ __ ] you won't
because you were the definition
of dumb
but there you go
have at it haters I want to show you a
video
because I mentioned Vicki Hartzler and
your family members at the holidays I
got a great video to show you this is
fantastic by the way
um this is Vicki hartzler's nephew
um
and I believe his name is Andrew is his
name and he put up a tick tock about the
uh Vicki hansler
um being uh crying on the house floor
right
and
apparently the reason why Vicki Arthur
was crying is because she knows someone
personally in her life
who would benefit from the marriage
equality act and because someone's
really close to her and her family she
wanted to make sure to rip that right
away from her family member but let's
listen
today a United States congresswoman my
Aunt Vicki started crying because gay
people like me can get married I hope
and pray
that my colleagues
will find the courage
to join me
in opposing
this misguided and this dangerous bill
so despite coming out to my aunt this
past February I guess she's still just
as much as a homophobe
let's be clear obergefell is not in
danger but people and institutions of
Faith are Aunt Vicki that's not right
institutions of Faith Like religious
universities are not being silenced
they're being empowered by the US
government to discriminate against tens
of thousands of lgbtq students because
of religious exemptions but they still
receive federal funding the Bill's
implications submit to our ideology or
be silenced
it's more like you want the power to
force your religious beliefs on to
everyone else and because you don't have
that power you feel like you're being
silenced
but you're not you're just gonna have to
learn to coexist with all of us
and I'm sure it's not that hard
thank you Andrew for the video
um if anyone out there has connections
we should have Andrew on the show why
not she can Andrew on the show
he knows Vicky personally I told you
yesterday about
my personal Vicki Hartzler story I went
to a parade for the Fourth of July and
she had a she had a float quote
not Junior quotes around float
so she had a float in the end the parade
and it was at literally this the float
was a box truck it was a second-hand
U-Haul piece of [ __ ] that she had
painted her name on the side of it that
was it
weren't passing out flyers wasn't
throwing the candy at the kids what the
[ __ ] Vicky Jesus Christ
she's running she was running for Senate
you remember there was a senate seat
open in Missouri Roy blunt
he uh
he dropped out
and I think Josh Hawley I believe he was
throwing his support behind Vicki
Hartzler
now we know how much
um how much a loser Josh only is if
that's true all right so uh that's how
you should treat your family members and
then especially this uh
the the
um marriage equality act
um
over the holidays but speaking of the
holidays now I don't normally play these
types of videos
the reason why is because Jimmy Kimmel
is going to knock me on YouTube
that's right and you can appeal the
Jimmy all you want they don't give a
[ __ ] they own this content they made the
content you know and they're really
they're paying the ass about this but
this video is [ __ ] hilarious so I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm gonna play it
today I don't care if we eat a copyright
strike or whatever I don't care if I
gotta cut it out we're gonna play it on
live show so if you're watching right
now in a replay and then it just skips
over this [ __ ] video it's it's
because
they they made me take it out right
whatever but we're gonna play it live I
don't give a [ __ ]
because it's funny as [ __ ] they did a
great job with this video they spent a
lot of time a lot of effort and it's
hilarious it's a [ __ ] great it's a
great commercial
um so I want to show it here on the live
show for you guys to watch it but uh
just for the people if this gets cut and
you're watching this on a replay which
thousands of people do watch is on a
replay if you're watching this on a
replay
just know this is the Jimmy Kimmel Mara
Lego Mara Lego commercials just go in
search in YouTube Camel uh Mara Lego and
you'll probably pull this up more than
likely this is [ __ ] hilarious watch
tis the season for treason
the morale Lego search and seizure
Edition where you can build Donald
Trump's Florida Mega Mansion and then
rate it FBI style
Junior help me hide the documents you
have so much fun hiding classified
material all over the estate under the
couch cushions inside the tanning bed
and beneath his ex-wife's tombstone
I am flashing nuclear secrets down the
toilet
open up FBI the only FBI interest is a
female body inspector gross use your
special agent skills to crack open the
face I'm trying to hide ink or a Lego
search and seizure also comes with Saudi
Nationals
[Music]
here to golf
reporters
look at my truck nuts and Eric with his
head stuck in a golf bag
find all the documents to indict the
former president we caught you
red-handed my hands are red that's just
ketchup tomorrow Lego search and seizure
Edition Rudy's secret tunnel sold
separately
[Music]
available at Walgreens
well there you have it
um Mara Lego and for your holiday season
I I don't know I think that'd be pretty
good too I think it'd be pretty popular
might be the most popular totally out
there this holiday season and the and
the Rudy's secret tunnel at the end so I
want to I want to say Jimmy Kimmel and
his team over there they did a great job
with this even if you cut it even if you
make me take it out you know because of
copyright and claim and all that [ __ ]
and but congratulations on them on the
Great Piece of content and you guys like
that that's hilarious and so you know we
like we We Love parody commercials over
here and that's fantastic again a lot of
work went into that thing a lot of work
went into the thing almost as much work
went into that commercial as Donald
Trump went into working to hide his
documents
holy [ __ ]
This Guy's in big trouble of course
um
we're probably gonna bring him up in
bonehead of the week I have a feeling so
I'm getting um I'm getting ready here as
I'm as I'm preparing see yeah I I wear a
lot of hats not just the [ __ ] them hand
I'm here on the Tony Michael's podcast
I'm trying to get uh the uh Gabe Sanchez
right now is working on the graphics for
bone Hen of the week and I'm working on
loading them into the studio so that way
we can play them here later
um but uh so but yeah we're going to
talk about the documents we're
definitely going to talk about the
documents thing for the bonehead of the
week
um this week and we're also going to
talk about this I don't know if you guys
seen this Gabe Sanchez pointed out we
might point this back out here later he
says it's almost like the new policy
that Elon announced in the exact same
exact same policy discussed by Twitter
in 2018.
um and it's referring to Shadow Banning
and did you guys see this there was a
there was another drop
and of course Gabe Sanchez paid a lot of
attention to it last night he was all up
in my DMs talking about this I could
give a [ __ ] less
I'll be honest with you I could [ __ ]
care less what they're with the right
Wings trying to trudge up as far as the
story I don't give a [ __ ]
what who gives a [ __ ]
at this point I mean has any of this
proven credible at all no Jesus Christ
the other day we went on a tirade here
on this show I don't know how many
different different ways we use to
[ __ ] describe Hunter Biden's ding
dong but I mean it was a lot it was a it
was a [ __ ] lot
it was a lot
so
um but you know there's [ __ ] like this
where these people are really upset
they're really upset that Twitter is a
private company
and they're really upset about
capitalism it's almost like they want to
be I don't know communist and they want
to control what a private company does
and how they [ __ ] how they use Ai and
how they use other tools and moderation
techniques to make sure that
misinformation isn't being disseminated
on their [ __ ] platform and on their
website how in the [ __ ]
can't D [ __ ] understand what
capitalism is these are supposedly are
self-proclaimed Capital loving [ __ ]
crackers they're crackers is what they
are they're saltine crackers cancel me I
don't give a [ __ ] these white
[ __ ] I'm so sick of this
nonsense
listen if you've ever been on Twitter if
you've ever been on Twitter you know
that there is a and people can confirm
us there is a black Twitter
Twitter has different spaces it lives in
different things right
and when on when on black Twitter
something starts to Trend it doesn't
make it in the trends it can't break
through
what well where where is Dr Carlson and
Charlie Kirks outrage that shadow
Banning happens on black Twitter where
where is it that it's not there because
they don't give a [ __ ] about that they
only care when they're shadow man they
only it's only cancer culture when their
ideas are being [ __ ] suppressed when
their eye their shitty ideas aren't [ __ ]
aren't [ __ ] making it out into the
world I'm telling you this is the
[ __ ] truth
ask anyone I hear Andrew on on uh on uh
well that's the wrong one Andrew and
here on Facebook says I'm a part of
black Twitter ask Andrew he'll tell you
I'm telling you it'll go around on black
Twitter and
on black Twitter but it won't make it
into the trend very rarely does anything
from black Twitter and and millions
thousands of comments millions of views
don't give [ __ ] the algorithm doesn't
care don't give a [ __ ] Shadow band
why why can't these [ __ ] white ass
saltine crackers understand that it's
not just you that's being suppressed
dummy and if you're gonna have outrage
about Shadow Banning if you're gonna
have outrage about the act of Shadow
Banning which everyone knows [ __ ]
happens everyone knows
then why not equal outrage well I could
only guess why these two white races
bigoted [ __ ] don't have equal
outrage it's really stupid it's really
stupid but
wow and you know me I want to show the
stupidity right out in the open so let's
let's listen to the stupidity people
measure the in
the in of what Twitter did to our voices
online in the calendar of 2020 the lives
that were lost
the kids that really had speech
impediments and delays and school
closures and of course the outcome of
the 2020 election all came from a
censorship regime from Twitter yep
that's right that's right it was it was
a it it was a website
with their Shadow Banning policy that
everyone knew before 2020 even got here
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
Charlie Kirk
you knew you knew in 2020 when you were
disseminating misinformation about covid
because that's what he's talking about
he's talking about the people who died
from the coronavirus in 2020 he's saying
the reason why those people died is
because Twitter wasn't making sure that
him and his [ __ ] seditious piece of
[ __ ] treasonous [ __ ] America
First Nazi party was making sure that
they weren't disseminating
misinformation about covid
the president United States stood up in
front of a microphone and basically said
well what if we inject bleach
what if we get disinfectant what did we
pour poison down in people's lungs would
that cure them what if we get
ultraviolet light underneath the skin
can we figure out how to do that this is
really stupid [ __ ]
he went on and on and on about fish tank
cleaner
hydrochloroquine you remember this
hydrochloroquine hydrochloroquine it
wasn't a [ __ ] cure
it wasn't it isn't
[ __ ] people were drinking fish cleaner
because it had it in it and killing them
poisoning them this is really dumb [ __ ]
but these two [ __ ] [ __ ] boxes are mad
that a that a that a a website that they
uh company owns wouldn't let them spread
their [ __ ] on their website this is
really stupid freedom of speech you
yelled and screamed into your own
microphone for [ __ ] months
freedom of speech my ass I know Gabe
Sanchez agrees with me on this freedom
of speech thing and this gets into the
Twitter thing and I know I know Gabe
Sanchez because he was I mean I'm
telling you last night my phone was like
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding all night long over this
Twitter 2.0 all night long gave zinges
and I honestly I could not give
two shits less about what Elon Musk
thinks of Shadow Banning but you know it
is a thing and I know we're gonna talk
about it today because I know I I
noticed when I was loading the um
bonehead of the wheat Graphics that you
made a special someone the dishonorable
mention right
um so which we had to also this is why
we have those categories right right
yeah because we put out the poll
yesterday and it was actually early
yesterday yeah I felt like five o'clock
my time right which usually we wait
later in the night and the reason why is
because of what happened right right
because we had this Twitter files [ __ ]
dump or whatever the hell it is and then
you have Kirsten Cinema doing the whole
I'm an independent I'm not a member of
the democratic but yeah no [ __ ] Sherlock
yeah you know you're not a member of the
democratic party dummy now thanks for
making it official we do not want you in
our party thank you I mean even her own
constituents were like yeah we we know
that I mean whatever you it never even
shows up to any sort of Town Hall she
hasn't run anything whenever that
happens she's always hiding in a
bathroom
I said in the first 30 minutes too that
that the people who do show up that that
showed up to volunteer for her campaign
I'm better the most [ __ ] piss people
on Earth this morning about that topic
yeah about her saying and this isn't the
first time she's pulled this type of
[ __ ] damn well you know she because she
originally she originally was part of
she was the green party right and then
switched the Democratic party right and
then now that she's part of the
democratic party and she's like well
actually I'm an independent convenient
how she switched it
right as the new uh term is about to
start with with their with the majority
before it's not like I mean I'm almost
certain she could have switched at any
point during the time well yeah she
could be a republican if she wanted you
can switch anytime you want the problem
that you have right and here's the real
issue that politicians in general have
is when you're elected to a certain
party in a state those constituents
elected you for that representation
right right so it's really difficult to
start switching your party affiliation
in that way
um yeah it is it's very much right right
so that's just how it happens I want to
go to one more thing and that we brought
up the other day and I'm trying to
figure this out before we go to bonehead
because we had a few minutes before we
get a bonehead
um I sent you some screenshots
um I actually you know we were talking
the other day and someone brought up
PornHub oh right yeah brought up Pornhub
and I said can we live stream to PornHub
um and I don't I haven't quite figured
it out yet but I was working on it
yesterday
um and someone brought up Pornhub here
in the chat so it made me think of this
um but it is it is a visual I do have a
PornHub profile uh and the Tony Michaels
now I don't know exactly I haven't
figured out I've got to apply to be a
model so Gabe Sanchez this is a real
thing if we can stream on PornHub I will
officially be a porn star I think now
I'm not we're not well I'm not going to
be posting nudes oh it'll just oh you
disappointed I mean I can [ __ ] send
you something to DM if you want I mean
if we want to get into the real Twitter
files right now oh well you know it that
that could be but here's the thing is
that it is possible
and it's possible that we will be
broadcasting our show in the coming
weeks or months when however coming
coming
all over all over the Internet yeah so
it's just Big Money Shot all over the
Internet
um but I don't know if it officially if
I if I get the access as a PornHub model
[Music]
I don't know if that makes me a porn
star or not I'm not really sure I don't
know I don't know I mean again I'm not
gonna be posting nudes over there I mean
unless there's a high you know uh you
know market for it then I might yeah
well my money shot
I mean we could and at the end of the
show it's like and for those of you
watching on PornHub that's the money
show instead of instead of um the [ __ ]
list maybe we change it to the money
shot I don't know yeah maybe you know I
mean maybe we're on PornHub and maybe
maybe just maybe if there's enough
audience over there we'll go exclusively
I'll tell YouTube to [ __ ] off I mean
yeah if there's enough people that are
go watch us on PornHub I'm I'm excited
about that so I don't know if the
audience has the same excitement that I
do of becoming possibly a porn star Tony
was sending me uh screenshots yesterday
and was like as I was trying to figure
it out and he's like so do you know
anyone and he's like okay
his Gabe's always bragging about how he
knows people in Tech because he worked
in Tech he works in dick and I was like
do you do you know anyone that PornHub
he's like no why would I I'm like it's
Tech right I mean I'm sure if I really
wanted to I could find somebody who had
some connection
uh-huh right I don't have a direct
connection oh okay oh yeah he's got it
in his Rolodex does everyone know what a
Rolodex is hey here's here's the thing
here's the thing is Gabe Sanchez did
admit in a in a private message that
PornHub it's probably 50 50. 50
pornography 50 Tech
so
um he is to some degree that he ruled
the technology is fueled by the porn I
would say they probably have a lot of
really good
um people who are good at Tech over
there that that aren't interested in
porn I mean they might be yeah they
might be that's not that they're not
actually in the porn industry right I
mean they all want to to run PornHub you
have to have I mean like you're talking
about millions of people coming
arriving to your site uh all the time I
mean not everybody me I mean they may
sometimes it takes a couple hits on
videos maybe a few minutes say there's a
couple like key strokes yeah that it
would take you know uh to get
you to do that um what I will say get
into the gutter way too easy you know
what I mean it happens yeah I mean when
yeah well look when you go to the hub it
is most definitely like to keep they
have the uptime the maintenance
um the up time you need to keep you keep
it up like keep the website up keep it
up sorry the pump time I mean the uptime
okay uh you need to have you got to keep
it up you know yeah you can't have it
you can't let it go everything you can't
let go down right yeah you got to keep
everyone
you know correct uh but yeah so you need
to you have to have reliable Tech in
terms of making sure that people can
upload video create accounts they can
watch I mean the analytics side of it is
I'm sure their team is is very very
talented considering how much data
they're able to extract they're able to
know okay this is the trend I mean a lot
of the I will say this the same
Tech the same like feature that you see
in uh YouTube where it's like oh here is
the most played popular sections that is
again porn drives advancement in
technology that is hands down whether I
mean it's the reason it's the reason why
we have uh payment gateways on the
internet right it's like the reason why
you can pay for [ __ ] on the Internet
it's the reason why we got DVDs in
Blu-ray these are the actual these are
technologies that were pushed like the
high definition this was all stuff 4K
this was all stuff that was you got to
get a good image you gotta get in yeah
you know I remember way back in the day
way back in the day when you had dial up
you remember you had to learn
the dial up and you go to you know I
might have been a teenager
um but you go to a porn site and you had
to download these [ __ ] pictures right
yeah and it's like slow right strange
yeah so usually usually you try to do it
Mike in the afternoon after school no
one else is home he gets you a few
pictures download and go outside you
know go play basketball shoot some hoops
ride the bike then come in and take a
look at your uh your treasure that you
after a few hours right slowly
downloading right you know yeah yeah
that's not the world that we live in
today and these these youngins out there
need to understand that that quick
access to porn was not as easy you had
to either sneak into
um your you know your parents room if
they had a porn stash of some mags or
something do you do people even know
what porn magazines are anymore I don't
know that's a good question do they sell
porn mags I haven't bought a bag they
sell porn I feel like if I went to a
7-Eleven I would be able to definitely
in the counter yeah you'd have to ask
for it like you would have to like
specifically be like hey can I get this
but I also want to say that in my look
my like neighborhood 7-Eleven I don't
know if there's actual like magazines
that are out on display there's a
newspaper there's like the USA Today
wall Street Journal New York Times that
kind of stuff but I don't know if you
can actually get
like there's no there's no longer a rack
of of magazines yeah right right but
that's what I'm saying is that I don't
know I mean do men are magazines even
going to exist
who knows I don't know
oh man the world good old porn mag I've
got I've got a whole uh stack of them
somewhere a whole stack of porn yeah but
don't you have stacks of porn I don't
have stacks what did you do what the
hell did you do I mean I I never had
stacks of porn yeah I had the internet I
had the internet they're getting Tech
guy over here he's like look Horn's been
on the internet forever speaking of
Internet did you watch this clip that I
just played to these two [ __ ] idiots
talking about I love it and how Twitter
they are yeah well it's the reason why
we suck
Twitter Twitter Shadow Banning is the
reason why we suck like get over it Fox
News is the most watched [ __ ] news
station you guys were disseminating
misinformation all over the place and
just because Twitter chose not to
participate in your nonsense and Shadow
ban you which everyone knows what shadow
Banning is it's not but also it's not
because like they're you know whether
someone's like oh is that shadow thing
is that she had a bad but we'll talk
about it in in bonehead because I have
the receipts because I'm going to call
out both Elon and not only but the head
of the head of trust and safety now is
that was the new one which is a new one
and doubling down on
just being [ __ ] idiots uh and we'll
talk about it and why certainly it's
almost it's almost like he got rid of
the best people and it was only the ones
that weren't the best and I just want to
clarify for fake Gabe it isn't okay look
all right so they there's a clear
definition of what shadow Bannon is but
also the same definition this is a
spoiler alert if you stick around for
bonehead of the week then you will see
this I know fake Gable stick around for
the whole time oh [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] oh
he can't watch us when when you look at
how Twitter defined that and it's not
it's visibility filtering is what it is
uh it's not Shadow Banning but they look
at accounts and they say Okay based on
your activity we will either push you
down we won't we we'll still allow you
on the platform assuming you haven't
done anything crazy or racist or bigoted
or whatever
but if you're still on the platform then
we won't show your account to as many
people we won't show your tweets to as
many people if you want to specifically
go and find that person you totally can
you can search them enter their handle
go to their profile whatever now this is
the thing if you think that is fascism
then I have a [ __ ] tweet to sell you
and that is they gave things Shadow
Banning is fascism on Twitter a pro a
company a private company now it's
publicly traded but it they it's their
platform dummy they own it
they get to publish if if Charlie Kirk
was so concerned about what what was and
what wasn't shown that he wanted to post
on [ __ ] Twitter they need to have his
own website oh yeah that's right he does
and they all do you [ __ ] post links
here every [ __ ] day of just nonsense
websites that are out there why the why
the [ __ ] does Twitter have to
participate in in these in these morons
nonsense and their misinformation they
don't have to that's the point it's
called capitalism big Gabe somehow fake
Gabe says not when they're directed the
government okay stop it I'm telling you
stick around for bonehead of the week
you'll probably find yourself on there
someday but I can tell you right now
that the that here's a little tldr of
something I'm going to talk about ready
the rule and the policy they have to
handle tweets and accounts that violate
and they do not want to platform further
they do not want to amplify as you saw
Charlie occur do not amplify because
it's not because of political views it
just happens to be that this guy's a
conservative a republican a Maga just
idiot that pushes conspiracies and
misinformation and can you imagine why
someone in Maga pushing an idiot who
created these conspiracy theories but
the same policy they had in 2018 when
they announced this basically they
announced this in 20 years whoa whoa
whoa wait you're saying that this policy
was prior to 2020
come on yeah not only that but here's
the thing this old Twitter 2.0 and I'll
talk about in a little bit 2018 they
publicly put on their blog and they're
look this is how we handle accounts
which is almost verbatim What Elon Musk
wrote in a tweet like three weeks ago
which is almost verbatim to what the new
head of trust and safety wrote just the
other day in response quote tweeting
elon's post about how to uh to reduce
the amount of impressions of hateful
content uh and tweets that are out there
it's almost like they knew this it's
almost like they knew exactly how to
handle this stuff and they just did the
same exact thing they were doing before
seems Seems sus seems sus when you're
trying to develop a uh a narrative and
somehow the big scary government yeah
was controlling Twitter all right
everyone let's just do the bonehead a
week everyone stick around we'll be
right back with bone of the week right
after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
reached
second hour you know what happens on
Friday during the second hour
you vote you decide for bonehead of the
week we break it down right here on the
Tony Michaels podcast bonehead of the
week bonehead of the week you got the
Twitter files and a big pile of [ __ ]
there oh yeah big pile of [ __ ] big pile
of [ __ ] because that's what it is steamy
pile of [ __ ] it's nothing nothing Burger
nothing is that is that what goes on to
nothing burger oh yeah it's it yeah a
lot of people like oh nothing Burger
there's nothing there no actually when
you bite into a nothing Burger you get a
mouthful of [ __ ]
because then the thing that you continue
to spew is just [ __ ] you know you're
already sending me links yeah I'm saying
I'm gonna imagine I'm imagining that
you're like let's get into this let's
yeah we could go either way we could go
yeah let's just jump into it let's see
yeah let's just do bonehead of the week
here it is
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
end of the week this Edition this week's
edition
we got some boneheads Gabe Sanchez how
do we vote for bonehead of the week
though how do we do this we have polls
on Twitter oh yeah and on YouTube oh
okay so go to at Tony Michael's pod on
Twitter and you can also follow us here
on YouTube go to the community tab you
can vote every single week and every
Friday we do bone end of the week here
on the Tony Michaels podcast and we give
a shortened version on Midas Touch
Network so go follow their YouTube
channel over there as well and check out
the um the clipped version we do a
little clip yeah yeah bonehead of the
week over there Everyone likes a little
clip but if you want to watch it you can
watch it here every single Friday or you
can download a game changes every single
Sunday on Apple's Spotify Google we get
thousands of downloads on just bonehead
of the week alone
every single week
so while you're there though make sure
while you're there subscribing on your
favorite directory that you leave us a
great review
so I know we got a good slate of
boneheads but the one bonehead that we
put on there I was like yeah he's gonna
win oh 100 now this full disclosure we
did the bonehead bowl a little early
this week so
some people that you think would be on
the list didn't make it on list because
it hadn't broke to the news and you know
that's how bonehead works but that's the
great part about how we do bonehead is
we always have special categories that
we can you know throw in those last
minute boneheads that's actually how it
happened yeah the alpha cook and the
dishonorable mention we had to have this
way because it was always like oh my God
now we gotta can you believe this person
yeah I mean literally this morning this
person found themselves on bonehead of
the week because of what they did when
the news broke right like it was it was
run it was like eight eight o'clock this
morning we're like yeah or my time eight
o'clock and it was easy it was easy it
was easy it was easy decision but here
was your decision this week for bone of
the week we had Peter Ducey and I'm
actually as I'm saying it I forgot he
was even on there yeah you know when I
was making the graphics I was like oh
yeah Jim Jordan and Donald Trump who's
the third one and I and I didn't want I
was like having this like moment of like
just blanking and I was like no I can't
look at the text I can't look at the
poll I'm gonna remember this it took me
a solid 40 seconds to like run through
things that I could remember people
doing this week and why we put them on
there because of yesterday something
that he said in a in a yeah in a White
House Press briefing of course and then
we had Jim Jordan Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan he's easy to put on this
list oh yeah he could be on this list
like every day probably if we had bone
end of the day Jim Jordan could be on
this list and then of course the Bonet
of all boneheads Donald Trump
um the [ __ ] Biggest Loser of all time
really honestly we should make this
loser of all time poll with Donald Trump
on it but uh let's do the Peter Ducey
story first I guess let's go through why
he's on bonehead of the week what is the
reason could you remember because I I'm
struggling yeah I think I remember what
happened yesterday yeah Peter Peter
Ducey you know irrelevant and forgetful
for sure uh but the reason is because
this the news of Brittany Greiner
correct coming back from Russia was
announced and Peter Ducey decided to uh
open his dumb mouth per usual in the
Press briefing room and ask a question
as to what was a good or better deal
um which brings up a larger discussion
of Donald Trump being the one that could
have could have been the only one that
have made this deal and not only that
but would have been able to get every
single uh U.S marine back to the country
which okay people seem to have a little
bit of okay so so what you're saying is
because there's actually two white dudes
in Russia that they're talking about
there's a professor I actually do not
have his name at the tip of my tongue
now and then there's this Marine Whalen
right
um another white dude now
obviously they made the deal for the
professional athlete Brittany Greiner
she is a black gay woman
and I believe
it is my belief that that is why the
right wing is pissed off and I am going
to stand by that belief and I don't need
to have anything but they're evidence of
them calling it wokism or some [ __ ] yeah
that's the reason why she's that was the
deal that Russia was willing to make and
the reason why is because Russia did not
want to make a deal with an unknown they
were they much rather honestly this this
is this is Vladimir Putin's idea because
he wants to be in the in the American
Media as much as he possibly can and
trading trading a marine was not going
to get him in the news as much as
trading Brittany Greiner right Putin
knew that the Russian the Russian
diplomats knew that when they were
negotiating and this is the deal that
the bite Administration could make right
is war burning grinder now here's Peter
ducey's question about the deal that
they made in the Press briefing
yesterday
um and again this is why he ended up on
bonehead second grade in this prisoner
swap why did Russia get such a better
deal
okay first off first off the idea the
idea that it is a better deal I don't
understand it was it was one prisoner
for one prison yeah right as an American
for a Russian right now they want to
make this big hoopla about this I don't
know there's a nickname for this guy I
guess he's an arms dealer right
apparently well they keep pushing The
Merchant of death yeah that's what he's
known as that's what he's known as this
guy who goes by the the nickname the
nickname Merchant of death I mean
there's literally a video we I called it
yesterday it's gonna do the video I was
like I can't wait for him to release a
video using the finger puppets and sure
enough he didn't do as many but he did
do oh The Merchant of death so it's they
want to compare
uh a successful black
U.S athlete Olympian who is also gay to
someone and I mean I saw tons of jokes
tons of jokes that people thought were
funny that were attacking Brittany
Greiner and being like oh they got a
it was like they got a plug and all we
got was Juwanna Man Juwanna Mann was the
joke that was being made which if
anyone's seen the movie it's about an
NBA player who gets
um or move from the NBA and he wants to
keep playing so he protecting a woman
and joins the wnb and the imaginary
little movie plays into their little
tray so they're like all we got was
Juwanna Mann so right out of the gate
you already had this like
uh this homophobic uh trans movie
misogynist kind of combination right
because they're like oh Brittany Greiner
is a man and uh she's a America USA
hating activist again you can live in
this country and still be proud of it
and also be vocal about it right and it
is and it is your Liberty to to and and
the reason why the reason why we have
the dod to fight for our Liberty is is
to speak out against the actions in our
country we're it's not China okay it's
not communist China dummies if that's
what they want and you know let's finish
up what Ducey says here really it's a
broader story but Ducey just ended up on
the bonehead look you know I've talked
about this uh and I'll say this again
here were our choices our choices was uh
Brittany or no one at all bringing home
one American or no American at all and
that's that special athlete we gave up a
prolific arms dealer who was convicted
of trying to kill Americans who was
called The Merchant of debt the
professional athlete is also an American
citizen
so let's not forget that
and I have explained how the Russians
have illegally uh treated totally
illegitimately uh treated his situation
I've been very clear on that we've laid
that all we've laid that out for you uh
and again the president felt that this
was an opportunity to bring Brittany
home he is going to continue to do
everything he can to bring Paul Whalen
home just like he did with Trevor Reed
just like he was able to secure Trevor
Reed's release okay so again when you go
back to the Weyland Story I mean you
could hash this out Trump had the
opportunity to get Waylon home he was
the president for crying out loud if his
vladie daddy if he had such a good
relationship like he claims then he
should have been able to get everyone
every American that was detained home
right I mean he could have got him on
one blame one beautiful plane the most
terrific plane trip ever back to America
the point is is they don't want Brittany
Greiner to come back to the United
States they wouldn't much rather she be
held in detainment in Russia than to
have another one of them black lesbian
women in this country that's literally
their thought process they do not care
they don't care that she's American
citizen they don't give a [ __ ] what the
situation is that Russia was going to
use her as a way to get into the news in
this country and really honestly you
know maybe maybe not it's good for Putin
I doubt it I mean you know he can't even
hold in a turd at this point but
um this situation here is that Russia
was willing to deal and do and do a
prisoner swap with Brittany Greiner and
the administration
for whatever it's worth took advantage
of that and made sure to get Brittany
Griner United States and this is and
this is also something for uh you want
to pull this article up
this is for fake game and every other
mag Republican out there that wants to
make a comparison to say oh this wasn't
a fair deal and they got a better deal
out of this okay
you've got the actual family
of Waylon
giving their response in support of what
the decision of in resp in support of
the decision that was made by President
Biden to trade Greiner
for The Merchant of death or GAO or bow
or whatever his [ __ ] name is and
can't you imagine the reason why
Waylon's family would be like this is
because when the opportunity comes
for Russia to trade Weyland possibly and
and seek his return to the United States
that the United States government and
the administration the president and the
and the department uh um uh of state
would not say well [ __ ] you we don't
like that deal so [ __ ] you right that's
the reason why is because they would
seek and want that same that same deal
if there's a deal to be made they want
their [ __ ] relative their loved one
to have that deal there wasn't the deal
for Waylon there wasn't
and as soon as there is the opportunity
which if it's under Joe Biden he'll
[ __ ] take it he will [ __ ] take it
and he will secure his return to his
foreign
one person one American citizen which
was a was a better deal than getting
back none so if all of these Republicans
want to push it oh well we shouldn't
have done that because that person hates
America that's not that's not at all
what this person stands for also fake
game okay they said uh
CNN says you're full of [ __ ] exclusive
Paul Whalen tells CNN is disappointed
that has not been done yeah he could be
disappointed by it but he supports the
decision and so does the family the
family understands the situation that's
at play right now Jesus Christ man again
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] Source in front of you
if it was their family member that was
the one being that had the negotiation
and it was either take them or nothing
at all that family would want them to
take their relative their loved one and
bring them back to you as you [ __ ]
idiot and they wouldn't say well no I'm
not I don't we don't want our relative
back because we can't we can't get every
prisoner that's there that's the point
you're Mis I mean you miss every [ __ ]
point no look and if you were that
person if you were wailing it yeah of
course you'd be like I'm disappointed
that I wouldn't be able to get out right
now obviously for both situations
illegitimate to hold them there
but you you look at what is you you look
at the situation and you still [ __ ]
hit the wall head on and keep running
thinking that you made an actual point
again you keep trying to push the idea
that
she wasn't worthy of it that an American
that's it exactly that's exactly what he
believes he believes she's not a real
American because she's black she's gay
and she's a woman she doesn't have the
rights to come she doesn't have the
right to come back here Gabe she's not
really a full citizen she's not a white
male she's not a straight white male so
it doesn't fit what he wants to have
America so he doesn't want her here they
don't want her here that's exact and I
would bet I would almost bet that the
next [ __ ] bonehead would say the same
[ __ ] thing Jim I don't report sex
crimes Jordan white evil he's he's on
the list this week because uh Eric
swalwell called him out and support
because there was a whole topic of
anti-Semitism and Trump being
anti-semitic and the question that was
brought up was does he support like or
rather was why did you delete your house
Judiciary GOP tweet about
Kanye in support of Kanye right because
if everyone remembers the tweet it was
Kanye Elon Trump and it was up there for
nearly two months it was up there for 56
days
and then it was deleted the day that
Kanye went on to Alex Jones and started
saying I love Hitler Hitler was a great
guy
we need to stop harassing Nazis we need
to let them do this do that look freedom
of speech okay yeah but again you know
freedom of speech but you are not free
of the consequences
of
your actions you say something there are
going to be consequences a a company or
a group of people can say you know what
I'm not going to buy your stuff anymore
I'm not going to support you anymore I'm
not gonna I'm not going to platform you
anymore you made the decision to make
these comments and Jim Jordan runs the
house Judiciary GOP account right and he
tweets from it and this is from your
what was that account if you're not uh
following it go follow uh what was that
with Gabe Sanchez on Twitter at what was
that show
um but you put your rep Eric swalwell
says do you denounce your house
Judiciary GOP tweet
um praising Kanye West that tweet was
not our account and that tweet's been
removed how would you how would you how
would you remove it if it wasn't in your
account so it's either your account or
it's not your account but either way how
do you know that it was removed and how
do you know which tweet we're talking
about it's really weird let's watch this
said a quick clip of this exchange so do
you denounce your tweets
that tweet was not our accountant
[Music]
okay so again
he says it's been removed and that was
not our so is it that that wasn't posted
on their account is it that it has been
I'm not sure what he's been lying about
or trying to lie about our gas light
more than in that tweet because I'm sure
people oh well this this is not the real
thing this is not what's there look you
can go to the tweet that I made from
what was that and I even put in the
archived version you can go to using you
know archive.org or the way back machine
you click the link and you can go back
to the house Judiciary and you're like
oh no that was this account is was is a
blue check mark that was created by you
know what you know what here's what it
this is what we should do we should make
sure that Twitter three point Twitter
files 3.0 make sure that they reveal
they reveal with internal tool
screenshots rather this was actually on
I want a full I want a full [ __ ]
committee investigation here this is so
important this is more important than
anything else in our democracy at this
point in history we need to know from
Elon Musk and I'm sure someone that
we're going to bring up here on bonehead
uh the the the safety and Twitter uh uh
Czar whatever the hell it is
um I I wanna this is the most important
investigation that we can have right now
I want a [ __ ] committee as soon as it's
just possible to investigate when and
where and what account this tweet was on
when it was deleted and I want
screenshots I want screenshots from the
internal tools that are being used over
Twitter I'm just saying so yeah if you
go to this tweet if you go to that tweet
and you go to the next tweet in the
thread there's only two tweets the main
one and the one in the thread okay yeah
and we can do this live on the show
right now we'll I'll show you that this
is actually their tweet okay so so this
is this is the the web archive right so
this is there so if you click that okay
well it's going to take me to a
different window so I'm gonna have to
click it go around hey hang on all right
all right they're gonna blame you like
ah you're you're you're you're you're
making [ __ ] up and it's just because
this tool is available to anyone just go
way back machine you look in there and
you write and you enter the URL you can
see archived versions if they have it
now here we see a tweet from the house
house house house Judiciary GOP at
Judiciary GOP it says Kanye Elon trump
it was sent from Jim Jordan's iPhone he
thought he was being so [ __ ] witty
now because you see their iPhone yeah if
you click
that link how should you share it not to
translate hit that one
and it takes you to
probably take it oh where are we now
whoa Judiciary GOP account
let's see it's run by Jim Jordan it's
got 272 points and keep in mind they
have 280 now this is the archived
version at the time so just a screenshot
capture at that time okay and the
account was created when
it looks like the 13th January 2013.
okay so almost almost 10 years they've
had this account gotcha okay so this
shows you from that tweet this is
actually their account so Jim Jordan can
say that's not our account and it was
deleted so either one is your account
and you deleted it or two it's not your
account but or you're aligned piece of
[ __ ] you're a lying piece of [ __ ] how
about that how about that Jim Jordan
you're a lying piece of [ __ ] and you
don't report sex crimes so you're you're
not only a lying Beast yet you're just a
[ __ ] vile scumbag so congratulations
to Jim Jordan again being on the bone of
the week he didn't make the Winner's
Circle but he did make the list of of
contestants yeah now we have some
special contestants here
um should we go to the DM now since
we're kind of on that subject yeah
should we get yeah why not uh so tell us
about the dishonorable mention here so
this is Barry Wise Barry Wise is a
journalist reporter will say wait wait
let okay so the reason why this is
significant yeah is because of the board
behind you the reason and the reason why
we have dishonorable mention is because
these stories come in late so something
happened yesterday Gabe Sanchez tell us
what happened yesterday to put Barry
Weiss as the dishonorable mention here
on bonehead of the week so yesterday
Barry Wise released Twitter files 2.0
the secret Blacklist like this some sort
of [ __ ]
young you young young adult novel almost
so now you said Barry Weiss is a
journalist why not Matt taibi in this
case he's the journalist that did the
original Twitter files right so they're
switching off so Matt TV did 1.0
followed up on the Twitter files
supplemental
then Barry Weiss went off and did 2.0
then mataibi is going to come back to do
3.0 I don't know how many
versions are going to come up you know
also like you would assume if there's
like a 1.0 with 2.0 3.0 that there's
like a 1.2 a 3.1 maybe that's the
supplement and they just mismarked it
but it's like uh they called it
supplemental but either way they're
they're doing this hot potato right now
with these files right they're trying to
prove that Twitter uh was in cahoots
with the US government at the time to
try to suppress the release of Hunter
Biden's dick pics that's really what it
comes down to
then they're trying to show that because
they worked in a malicious manner they
were actually trying to suppress
right-wing voices
now
again this act of them bringing down
right-wing accounts or not bringing down
I mean unless they're banned or
suspended
but them taking down these things or or
moving them down in the hierarchy of
what's actually uh promoted on Twitter
so someone called that shadow Banning
right right they would call it Shadow
Banning it's called visibility filtering
um and so it's when you say
uh actually you know what if you click
in here which this is this is a good
summary of the of the Tweet here
so this is what e-line is this the one
year is this the one you want here yeah
yeah so Elon says on November 18th so
this is like three weeks ago he says new
Twitter policy is freedom of speech but
not freedom of reach
so keep in mind what he's saying you're
saying you could say whatever you want
but Twitter as a company has the right
to say ah you know we're gonna suppress
the amount of reach that you have as an
account it seems like Elon is using his
dictorial power here and maybe he's just
being influenced by government officials
I'm just saying right so then he says
negative slash hate tweets will be Max D
boosted and demonetized so no ads on or
other revenues or other Revenue to
Twitter you won't find the Tweet unless
you specifically seek it out which is no
different from the rest of the internet
he's describing he's describing
um what a word that we just used I think
isn't he in that what shadow Banning
really is yeah and if fake Gabe wants to
talk about which visibility filtering
versus Shadow Banning fine you can say
they're the same thing but what Elon is
saying right now is he says if you're an
account and you put hate speech or other
things out there then we're going to say
no one should be able to see your
account like normal they have to
actively go out and see the Tweet okay
now this is from 2018.
this is uh two former employees of
Twitter
and coming forward to talk about Shadow
Banning people like oh Shadow Banning
Shadow Banning Shadow Banning so they
say the best definition we found for
shadow bandage deliberately making
someone's content undiscoverable to
everyone except the person who posted
unbeknownst to the original poster so
that would that would be same that
shadow Banning would say that everything
is unavailable everything is unavailable
to not just a specific hateful right
it's it's one person can see it and it's
the original person who posted that
would be the only person everyone else
can't see it so even if they look for it
they couldn't find it even if they were
linked to it they couldn't see it
that is what that they are saying right
now so in 2018 they put up there's a
[ __ ] FAQ on the website they gave you
can go there this is also a specific
blog article post that they put out for
this he loves he loves links he loves he
loves links he loves links so you can
easily also fake if you want to [ __ ]
just search Twitter shadowband blog
you'll find it in here they say we do
not Shadow ban because remember Shadow
Banning would say that it's the
suppression of everything so no one
could ever see it right you'd be
basically
and that's every single post that you
would post right so exactly so for
instance if I was Shadow band it
wouldn't matter what the hell I was
posting it would not matter what I even
if I just posted hey hey can you see
this tweet you know you get that a lot
like uh testing testing in my shadow man
you can shout into the void and no one
would hear it which means you could say
the craziest racist bigoted homophobic
transphobic xenophobic things online and
no one would ever see it Gabe you might
hey you might be you might be a a Ally
to Shadow Banning and you just don't
know it go ahead sorry so so basically
what they say here is they say shadow
Banning is the complete suppression
where no one would be able to find it
see it interact with it only the person
who posted so again you're basically
just yelling into the void and being
like hello hello and nobody responds
it's just like a private diary at that
exactly pretty much it's just like if
you had your account on private it would
be the equivalent of Shadow Banning now
this is where it gets interesting you
see we do not Shadow ban you are always
able to see tweets from accounts you
follow although you may have to do more
work to find them like I don't know go
directly to their profile and we
certainly don't Shadow ban based on
political viewpoints or Ideology Now
go back to elon's real quick yeah let's
let's uh let's see if we can go back to
you're talking about the graphic that I
just showed of his tweet right yeah of
his tweet hmm let's see what that says
so he says you won't find the tweets
unless you specifically seek it out
which is no different that sounds that
sounds like this 2018 article it sounds
like the same thing it's almost it's
almost like it's not a new Twitter
policy it's almost like he's trying to
you know say it is when it actually
isn't now there's another part here
negative slash hate tweets will be Maxi
boosts and and demonetized so no ads or
other Revenue to Twitter now go back to
uh go back to the one that was from 2018
hmm let's see here
okay here we are
uh if you uh there we go we do not rank
tweets and search results we do this
because Twitter is most useful when and
immedi relevant these ranking models
take many signals into consideration and
best organize them time relevance we
must also adjust the bad faith actors
who intend to manipulate distract from a
healthy conversation so basically what
they're saying is they have an algorithm
and they have a way in which things are
ranked and they will de-rank D Boost Max
D boost uh demonetize the accounts that
are malicious in nature and shooting out
hate speech it's almost like it's the
same thing that he said here yeah it's
almost like the same exact thing he's
saying here crazy very weird it's almost
yeah go ahead and I almost like Elon is
just doing what he normally does which
is right say he created something yeah
but really somebody else did it before
him so he's taking credit
very interesting very very very
interesting this all together Twitter
files 2.0 was another [ __ ] pile of
[ __ ]
because Barry Weiss only showed us and
you know if we want to go actually I
think there's something that's more
important and there's a link that I sent
you yeah
um which is
from it's a screenshot of one of her
tweets
and it's from her 30 tweet thread which
she did at 30 so this is 30 tweets okay
okay so which um is it the what was that
or is it the second one if you go to the
the second one okay get it yep now this
is what I want people to to keep in mind
and fake Gabe this is important okay
listen up this is very important because
it talks about privacy
all right so Elon Musk gave Barry Weiss
and mataibi direct access to the
internal tools that are used by Twitter
employees which has further developed
into a new uh development I will say so
what I said was I'm pretty sure users
did not consent to report reporters
journalists
invading their privacy okay whether it
was them directly in the tools or them
over someone's shoulder [ __ ] taking
photos
and Republicans like fake Gabe are
totally okay with this because it's to
own the libs now right can you imagine
can you imagine if a journalist was had
access to internal tools to to suppress
to suppress the speech of Republicans oh
my God they would lose crazy it is it
would be I don't know it would seem like
somebody who is like all about owning
their privacy like Republicans and don't
want big government and all this
[ __ ] they wouldn't want that but but
they're okay with it because it's to own
the libs now if you scroll down I just
want to point out a few things here so
she says one of the accounts that Rose
to level scrutiny was Libs a tick tock
yeah because it's a [ __ ] transphobic
account that targets people and sends a
bunch and incites people to attack them
okay
an account that was on the trends
Blacklist and was again is it designated
as do not take action on user without
consulting s-i-p-p-e-s what does that
mean I couldn't figure out last name
what that means and I was trying to read
your thread but I was like hey uh what
does that mean so it's a it's a
committee it's a group of people who
make a decision based on the content
there are two what you're saying so what
you're saying is is literally Libs of
tick tock account on Twitter gets
special treatment where no one can take
action against this account until they
consult with this committee the
s-i-p-pes right so you're saying
literally what they're claiming that
these people that they don't get special
treatment are the ones actually getting
special treatment now you may argue oh
well it's it's because they're trying to
silence them but they're actually giving
them special treatment with a special
Consulting committee to make sure every
single piece of their content is that is
supposed to be seen is seen and what I
mean by that is anyone and everyone who
has a user account on Twitter can report
any tweet they want to now regardless
rather that report results in any kind
of uh
um recommendation or any kind of
punishment against that post it doesn't
matter you as a user have the right to
report any [ __ ] post or any account
that you want to yeah but what is
happening in this situation and I'll
scroll down and show the screenshot here
in a minute is that Libs of tick tock a
vile [ __ ] account who is a right
alt-right account who like you said
disseminates just absolute lies to
incite people to to attack these
accounts to attack other accounts on
other platforms and and even calling
bomb threats to children's hospitals
that they get special treatment on every
single one of their posts that is
reported by a special committee
it is ridiculous to say that these
accounts weren't the accounts that were
actually getting the special treat I I I
highly doubt even the [ __ ] I post on
Twitter which is most the time I mean I
called Christian cinema this morning a
[ __ ] on on Twitter which most I saw I
saw Trent was was trending Trent was it
trending okay but um but here's the
thing is that I am almost sure that my
account doesn't have some [ __ ]
special counsel yeah yeah that that I
get special treatment because here's the
screenshot that you know where they get
the special treatment lives with Tick
Tock now this is a screenshot that Barry
Weiss has taken over the shoulder of
someone is that is that what yeah yeah
so they have uh the question last night
was does Barry Weiss and mataibi because
they were I guess they were both given
company laptops and access to certain
things they were added to the slack
Channel basically they were given way
more access than you would normally get
I mean basically what these people are
these journalists uh are doing is they
have they're doing PR for a company
they're hired as journalists to
investigate but really what they're
doing is PR for Elon Musk right
but in this screenshot it says uh you
know do not take action on user without
consulting with SIP PES which stands for
site Integrity policy policy escalation
support okay so what they're saying is
is a Twitter a Twitter employee who
would take action on other accounts
they get the discretion Libs of tick
tock got special treatment yep they got
special treatment to make sure that a
Twitter employee would not take action
without the consultation from the Sip
and this is and keep in mind this is
taken right now okay this isn't from
months ago right this is right still
getting special treatments they still
get special treatment they still have
this committee they still have this
condition in their [ __ ] code that
says hey flag do not take this action
this is still exists now here's the
reason that This concerns or should
concern a lot of people is because uh go
back to that photo yeah okay uh yeah let
me bring it up here in in that photo
right there's a lot of pii information
which is personal information okay your
email which if you want to access the
email you click that button it would
reveal the email in the top right in the
in the bottom right you're able to
access the IP addresses so yesterday I
think we were talking about
um
yeah someone reposted yeah he was on a
Twitter space right and I said well if
he made an account in a different IP
address like he was in L.A maybe maybe a
different cell phone or something
different it would have a different IP
address so you can track IP addresses to
know like oh great I want to ban this IP
address and I want to block them out so
they aren't able to create another
account that's what that lower section
is so this is the activity where they
were and what time they logged in the
middle section is their account that
says you know how many tweets they have
how many followers uh what's uh how many
people they follow I don't know I think
that maybe he's a ratio I'm not sure
what the 0.09 is but in there it says uh
high profile active notification Spike
Trends Blacklist recent abuse strike
Twitter blue verified multiple accounts
strike count two they did two things
high profile not safe work view because
they're posting things that are not safe
for work and there's some other tags so
these are just labels these are
attributes that are added based on
conditions they met so in other words
when a Twitter employee logs in in this
internal tool they can see the tags that
are on any exactly
also see what the actions were taken so
what got that like where were the
violations then if you go over to the
left side
oh
okay you can look at their timeline this
space is recordings the live videos the
communities they're a part of people I'm
not sure what guano is yet outside of
batshit you can see their email their
phone the list they've created are part
of the direct [ __ ] dirty old [ __ ] the
part that is really concerning is direct
messages yeah right so now whether you
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second wait a
second are you telling me that there's a
journalist standing behind a Twitter
employee
who has access to this internal tool who
could click that button direct messages
and see not just Libs of tick tocks
direct messages but any users direct
messages is that what you're saying it
would appear it would appear that way
you know you've isn't that isn't that I
don't know I doesn't that break terms of
service doesn't that break I mean Friday
as a user I can tell you I did not agree
to a condition in the terms of service
that said I would allow a third party
like a reporter to get access to my
private account now I doubt that my
account is that controversial that it
would have these flags or I don't know
you should see some of the [ __ ] I've
sent you in the DM oh who knows but this
is an invasion of someone's privacy in
the sense that you're you're allowed to
go you're
the new and this is this is where okay
so now that we've seen that you can you
can look into someone's account this is
the internal tool it's a dashboard that
you can look through all we've never
seen this before right this is the very
first time we've ever seen this before
have we yes in 2020 Vice released an
article that talked about it was uh it
was a it was an account or sorry the
article was about hackers getting access
to internal tools through social
engineering
and what they ended up doing was they
released uh some internal screenshots
actual screenshots not photos taken over
someone's shoulder right what you what
you mean a screen at like a screen uh
grab where you're grabbing the image of
the screen as opposed to right again
taking a photo of a screen right right
exactly so that is that was released in
2020 okay by the way the proper way the
proper way to take a screenshot is to
screen grab it not to take a picture of
a screen this is like this is very much
uh project Veritas style right well oh
yeah [ __ ] got that boom it is it is
Elon so yeah it is which I actually have
a tweet in my drafts that's going to
call Elon out for this well you better
be careful they'll be looking at it in
the internal tools he's going to look at
the stuff and see all the stuff that we
say about him but oops maybe they like
dick pics so much that's why they like
to take the the snapshots I don't know
but in the scenario
they revealed they they revealed
something that had already been revealed
two years prior people already knew
these internal tools existed people
already knew that there was this way in
which to handle tweets and accounts
content moderation wait wait wait wait
you're telling me that Twitter files 2.0
is a nothing Burger too yeah it's
another here I'm so I'm so surprised
Twitter 1.0 supplemental and 2.0 1.0
revealed that uh hey you can't just go
posting around uh non-consensual dick
pics and photos of naked people what
yeah you can't do it sorry it's against
terms of service and there's a and what
it really proved is there's a reporting
process so when those things are online
and there's not consensual that you can
report them you're telling me people can
report tweets that's nonsense so then
Twitter supplemental yeah revealed that
which would really it really should be
1.1 one right or one point yeah it
should be like 1.1 or something right
yeah but anyway so then so then
supplemental revealed that uh was Jim
Baker was General Counsel now the person
that would have said a lawyer right a
lawyer the person who would have
revealed or or rather vetted like what
2.0 did they would be like uh I don't
know if we could show those things that
guy was fired okay so there's that
before he's doing his job and then 2.0
as we've seen here just shows you that
there was a internal tool to moderate
content in accounts for violating terms
of service hmm you mean the company had
a way to make sure to take down accounts
and to make sure that these accounts
weren't violating terms of Sir that
seems ridiculous yeah pretty crazy seems
ridiculous that they would develop tools
to make sure that the [ __ ] that they
didn't want on their website didn't end
up on their website that sounds really
ridiculous so that's 1.0 supplemental
2.0
Umi and I guarantee it's going to be
another nothing Burger but there's one
final tweet and then we can move on that
I want to show just trying to educate
people as well as fake Gabe uh because
he's so adamant about this suppression
so this one here no no what's the one
before
the first one no no the last one I sent
you I think yeah he's got he got so many
links here sorry I I bring the receipts
to action they're the protection is is
is a high today and there's a lot of uh
there's a lot of evidence that we gotta
is this it is this the one you want yeah
yeah so if you scroll up that one we'll
start there okay right here you know
scroll up
sorry okay so in this tweet it's the
same screenshot right so what was
revealed last night that people were
able to figure out that there was an
overlay of a user's account which was
air uh div anyway it doesn't matter it
was a user account and this said this
couldn't possibly be new Twitter head of
safety Ella Irwin oh so they figured out
who it was that was logged in so then
they said it couldn't possibly be the
new head of trust and safety letting
this person take photos of a back-end
tool
from behind their back right
then you scroll down and this is how the
new head of safety responded so this is
this person they're accusing of doing it
yeah yeah so who who then
[ __ ] reveals herself
she says correct for security purposes
these screenshots requested came from me
so we could ensure no pii uh so personal
information was exposed we did not give
the access to reporters and no reporters
are not accessing users DMS so this is
again
you've got the head of trust and safety
running around taking screenshots from
her phone
of internal tools of accounts
that are all right-wing accounts by the
way they're all right they just happen
to be writing accounts and they're
bringing it up
and what they hate about it is the fact
of like oh God forbid because blips of
tick tock was like oh my God they
revealed tonight and Charlie Kirk was
like they reveal tonight that we were
suppressed and our voices were
suppressed and all this [ __ ]
actually what they really revealed was
there was a whole process to moderate
content in accounts that were posting uh
[ __ ] against terms of service well again
here's the other thing too here's the
other thing that I want you to remember
is like Gabe said all these screenshots
and [ __ ] came from right-wing accounts
they did not post not one not one
left-wing account and they won't right
they won't post a left-wing account
because it's going to show the same [ __ ]
it's going to show the same thing that a
controversial left-wing account that has
a lot of followers that post a lot of
stim may or may not be against terms of
service is gonna have the same [ __ ]
moderation tools it's gonna have the
same consideration for moderation that's
why they're not going to post it they
won't show you the evidence all of it
because it doesn't fit their narrative
and that is why that is why Barry Weiss
is the dishonorable mention this week
now I want to move to the alpha cook
yeah but before I do I do want to say
this
that there is more substance inside of a
Rudy Giuliani covered fart than there is
in any of the Twitter files that's all
I'm doing yep I'll leave it I'll leave
it there so let's go to the alpha cook
of the week Kirsten Cinema if Sanchez
why is Santa she's a Democrat see we
don't discriminate what she was well we
don't discriminate against Republican or
Democrat here on bonehead bonehead of
the week we do not discriminate against
any oh my God okay
um Kirsten Cinema yeah
she's been blaming this for a while
because she made a video and everything
so and it it really feels like she made
this announcement
since Warnock won and I'm almost
guessing games I'm almost guessing here
that if Warnock would have lost she
would not be doing this nope nope nope
because again she could say this at any
time she could have said this last year
she could have said it [ __ ] while she
was on the [ __ ] or in the toilet hiding
from her constituents she could have
done at any point
any point but she waited
until the results of the Georgia runoff
election here's why that's important
because before the runoff because every
single Democratic senator who ran as an
incumbent won
and Democrats picked up a seat in
Pennsylvania okay now this is important
and the reason why it's important is
because it changes the majority number
from 50 50 which means the vice
president is the 51st vote which gives
Democrats the majority in the leadership
but not all the power in the Committees
now with that 51st seat where
where uh uh the Pennsylvania seat was
lost and Warnock won the runoff which
puts Democrats at 51. it means that the
full power of the subpoena in the Senate
committees is based on Democrats they
get the majority in the Committees they
also have the majority in the Senate but
what it also means is that it basically
makes Kirsten Cinema
irrelevant it makes it real relevant I
mean that's what it is absolutely
irrelevant so not only does it make sure
that our democracy is safe from a bunch
of fascists but it makes her to where
she can't sway the Senate yep so it
feels like that she's hedging her bet
only on one point and one point only is
attention seeking that is what all this
is the entirety of it none of it is
anything but attention seeking what is
the link that you sent me here so this
this is a this is the interview where
she you know so this officially with
Jake Tapper yeah yeah okay so this is
now there's there's several clips that
acin put together uh from this interview
but this one I think is the most
important because of what she uh how she
responds to the question okay well let's
watch this this clip of interview with
Senator Kirsten Cinema switching her
party affiliation
you're here to make a significant
announcement
it's on an independent
actually I think it makes a lot of sense
you know a growing number of arizonans
and people like me just don't feel like
we fit neatly into one party's box or
the other okay I gotta stop right there
because I've been saying this all day
and I'm going to say it here again
the people of Arizona you [ __ ]
bonehead Kirsten Cinema voted for the
senator of the democratic party they
they literally went into the polling
Booth saw the D next to your name saw an
R next to someone else's name and voted
for you as the affiliate of the
democratic party in the Canada the
Democratic party they did not vote for
an independent you [ __ ] bonehead yeah
and this is what really pisses me off
about this is that if she was really
gonna do this she would wait until the
election where she was actually
announcing that she's running for this
seat again I mean wait till that time we
know and her constituents know that
she's not really like
in comparison people are like ah well uh
we'd rather have a Democrat a democrat
in office and have a republican like we
don't like her like she doesn't she does
not have Town Hall she does not actually
talk to her constituents and I wonder
why
she she runs away into the bathroom now
I'm not saying that people should do
that or not but if you don't talk to
your constituents they're gonna get kind
of pissed off because you made a promise
them to communicate for transparency to
be open to listen to them and give
feedback and get feedback from them to
make decisions on how to vote to better
represent them in the state of Arizona
but when you don't do that people get
pretty [ __ ] pissed because they feel
ignored
now if you were and I I have a feeling
if she was on the ballot
this time around
that she would have uh lost
you know and the idea that when she goes
up for her next election and she goes as
an eye
I she's now opened the door for a
Democrat to go against her like she's I
get you know she's
now that she's a Democrat or now she's
independent right like she's she's kind
of future proofing herself into what she
can go against right because like I'm
not exactly sure how the primary Works
in terms of now is she just on her own
well she she is she will appear if she
chooses to run she will appear on the
ballot in the general election now some
people have said well that'll split the
uh I I absolutely do not believe that
that will split anybody's [ __ ]
decision if anything it'll peel off
Republicans she is not appealing to
anyone on the left at this point and
really the the only people she's gonna
appeal to is is the [ __ ] right
Wingers and she may right up into the
lead up of that race she may start
adopting Q Anon conspiracy theories to
try to see if she can she can peel off
some of that electorate because as she
[ __ ] walks away from the Democratic
party in Arizona she's not going to get
any Democratic parties vote they're
going to tell her to [ __ ] off right and
the other thing that I want I want to
stress here is this state that the
Arizona Republican parties it's in
[ __ ] shambles why do you think Blake
Masters and Kerry Lake were the nominees
for governor and Senator right there
it's in shambles it's the crazies that
are running that [ __ ] Arizona party
and they're losing so right fine if you
want to go there go for it you know
whatever but this is her you know the I
is for irrelevant it's not foreign
well let's let's finish uh what the
irrelevance of her is and what her take
is on her relevance I mean Independence
sorry and so like many across the state
and the nation I've decided to leave
that partisan process and really just
focus on the work that I think matters
to Arizona into our country which is
solving problems and getting things done
so
your voting record is pretty capital D
Democratic I mean your views are
generally that of a moderate Centrist
Democrat how does leaving the party
change how you do your job well I don't
think anything will change about how I
do my job
um arizonans sent me to the United
States Senate to be an independent voice
no they did not I'll continue doing that
what I think is important about this
decision and this move is that I'll be
able to show up to work every day as an
independent and not be you know stuck
into one party's demands of following
without thinking and as we've seen in
recent years both parties have created
this kind of requirement or a pull
towards the edges that you just
unthinkingly support all of One party's
viewpoints it's made it difficult to
find folks who are willing to work
together and solve problems okay so you
don't actually have to be an independent
to do that yeah you actually don't have
to be an independent but what she's
doing is she is formally sane
hey look guys uh if I want to [ __ ]
everything up and hold something hostage
it's because I'm an independent it's
because I'm a [ __ ] independent right
that is what she's saying she's like
yeah
yeah it really does but that's what
she's doing she's now saying look guys
if I vote on something or don't vote on
something and I hold this in [ __ ] uh
some sort of Quorum where we're not able
or like hold it hold it hostage then uh
it's because I'm an independent and I'm
an independent thinker and I'm a [ __ ]
open-minded free thinking independent
who doesn't have to form herself to
liberal or conservative I just do what I
want because like I'm an independent I
hadn't considered this yet
could this be could this be Kirsten
Cinema's attempt to be a Maverick
remember there was a guy oh there's a
guy that ran for president and there was
a guy and I think that'll go over really
he was really popular in Arizona he
might have even have been a senator
there for a long time what was his name
and he seems like he was a war hero but
the the next the the winner of this
week's bonehead didn't think he was a
weird Warrior oh right could it be that
that Kirsten Cinema is trying to court
John McCain voters in Arizona by being a
uh uh independent or a as Donald Trump
Jr would say uh Maverick yeah Donald
Trump Jr would say Maverick
um maybe that's what she's trying to do
I didn't consider the word maverick
until just now well Maverick does have
an eye in it so it does it does right
well the eye is for irrelevant like Gabe
Sanchez said speaking of irrelevance
now let's go back to our contestants
here for bone Hen of the week of course
we had um the Cheeto dust mobster on um
a mobster oh see I I messed up the
Cheeto dust q and honor and the junior
desk q9 we had gym honorable sex drives
Jordan but Gabe Sanchez who was who was
the winner of this week's bonehead of
the week poll I mean
I'll say it again little hands down
Donald Trump oh my God he won hands down
it was no it was really nice there was
no contest the name was out there and
people were like oh yeah we found out he
stole even more documents we found out
that while he was President he got a
19.8 million dollar private loan from a
a company that has ties with North Korea
wait you're telling where
he was on the bone end of the week Poll
for more than one reason surely not
surely not Donald Trump so I I figured
he was going to be on for the documents
thing but really this morning
groundbreaking news
breaking news the special Master is now
gone
um and and the reason why the special
Master is gone is because Donald Trump
and his legal team they missed the
deadline to appeal to the 11th courts
this we talked about this last week on
bonehead the 11th circuit because judge
Cannon was our
um bonehead last week about the 11th
circuit because her decision was struck
down with the special Master by the uh
she kept doubling down that's right her
being an idiot that's right but here's
the thing is that Donald Trump did not
appeal the Striking down of the special
Master it's almost as if
and and maybe I'm just out on a limb
here it's almost as if his legal St his
legal counsel who is under
um scrutiny for contempt apparently now
um which is some fines and things no no
prison time for this this kind of action
right it's almost like they were like no
we are not going to appeal for you we're
not going to do that we won't represent
you you couldn't he couldn't get anyone
to agree that like hey we should and
maybe even he was like there's no way
this Supreme Court even the one I
selected and hand-picked is gonna go
with me well we already know he's you
know very upset he was already very
upset with the Supreme Court as of late
in the decisions they made that were
going against him and other things but
like even this this is something where
you know just on Truth social this
morning Jesus Christ is a huge cup of
coffee the guy is off the [ __ ] can you
can you give me can you give me some can
you give me the link there yeah um I'll
I'll um but the other the other thing
too is that
on top of all of this
yesterday the justice department
requested for the judge to hold the
whole Trump team in contempt over the
Mar-A-Lago case and just to kind of
summarize what happened basically they
had Christina Bobby the fall person as
the
um
as the the holder of Records or I forget
the actual the terms she's the one who
said custodian the custodian of Russia
she signed she signed the on June June
yeah on June 3rd she signed a document
that said yep you guys got everything
you have it all you know where it is we
give it to you it's all done wrong
answer two months later we find out on
August 8th that Mar-A-Lago is uh legally
searched by the FBI because they lied
and they still had documents so
then you find out this week of course
the other reason is because Donald Trump
had even more documents in another
[ __ ] story oh surely not
it's it just doesn't ever end it's just
non-stop they continue so the ideal the
idea that Trump and his team would ever
tell the truth like is insane we just
have to know that whenever they speak
it's a lie right
you mean you mean what you're saying is
almost everything that Donald Trump says
is a lie this seems
this seems like what has been going on
for a long time I mean we'll we'll sub
out the Twitter files and we'll just say
like everything Trump says is [ __ ] oh
man there you go because that's what it
is right the guy lies they continue to
lie they they made I mean Christina Bob
is totally screwed uh so is Elena Haba
Jim trustee all of these people are
incredibly incompetent they do not
actually know how to handle this [ __ ]
show it's almost creative for that it's
almost like he can't hire a competent
attorney because no one wants to
represent him and everyone wants to get
paid exactly or the work that they do
right because the one competent attorney
that he does have he had to pay him in
advance what's this guy's name in
Florida three million it was uh way yeah
whether he's went through so many
attorneys right there's so many of these
[ __ ] chuckleheads that obviously this
guy's has enough brains to get paid in
advance uh Chris Chris Case that's
actually Chris he's the one yeah he's
the one that actually got his money in
advance yeah I mean that was the biggest
amount that was the biggest amount that
they had paid out to a legal fund
because he needed a three million dollar
retainer because the guy's not needed
he's like look all of these people have
not been paid by Trump over the years it
has been again and again and again and
again and he's like even even Rudy even
Rudy's like yeah he hadn't paid me I
mean that was the whole thing Rudy was
like what twenty thousand dollars was it
a day or a month oh I mean twenty
thousand dollars a minute why not when
you when you got your hands down your
pants tucking your shirt into your balls
why not charge twenty thousand dollars
per minute everybody's gonna pay for you
know right Rudy's got to pay for all the
hair dye obviously right it's expensive
[ __ ] it's expensive [ __ ]
well here is here's a post now this is
from seven hours ago which he also re he
reached oh God what is it called okay he
quit the truth because he didn't read
well because it was like a quote tweet
but and what he did was he also like
truth
and she they should have come up with a
different name that rolls off the tongue
I'm just saying he here's what he posts
seven hours ago now this is um we're at
uh two we're about it just past 2 uh p.m
eastern time here
um on the Tony Michaels podcast but
here's what he posed seven hours ago
what is going on with the app and it's
on caps yeah I mean there is nothing
that is lowercase here he's got it's
stuck the button is stuck now he says
what is going on with the FBI and the
justice department question mark they
seem to be totally out of control with
an exclamation point there is right now
a weaponization uh which again he's
putting quotes around that and it's not
the same as anyways a weaponization of
Justice the likes of which our country
has never seen before it is like the
likes we never seen which is a very
former president be such a [ __ ]
criminal that the department Justice had
to Bear down on them and then not only
is he uh a criminal but he continues to
crime and then right hey you know this
is a good time to run for president
right Jesus but the other thing is the
common phrase the likes of which our
country has never seen before you could
literally put anything in it you could
be like the donut sale uh was the likes
of which our country has never seen
before any uses that all the time
all the time okay it's he continues here
the Twitter and Facebook Scandal has
already proven to be with the possib
possible exception of spying on my
campaign oh Jesus their most Sinister
act in history holy [ __ ] so not allowing
Hunter Biden's dick to show up on
Twitter is the most Sinister act in
history I mean other than his campaign
being spied on because he was colluding
with a foreign power who's An Enemy of
the State right anyways even the rhinos
and the and the we week are openly
admitting that the 2020 election was
rigged but in the dark way than ever
thought possible so many lives destroyed
only one well I said this the other day
this is the most amazing time in history
yeah think about this the former
president United States is going to be
responsible for putting possibly
thousands of people in prison and
incarcerated
thousands
are going to go to jail prison be
convicted of criminal charges at the
behest of a former president it is
absolutely mind-blowing that that is a
real possibility here over the next
couple years including himself and
really what a time to be alive to watch
this guy absolutely unravel in front of
our eyes I mean well the funny thing
about his rant there he talks about
Twitter because obviously it's about
this Twitter files uh nothing Burger
[ __ ] show but he has to bring that up
because yeah yeah because there's also
and I don't know if the LIE the lives
that were like you know like oh lives at
risk kind of thing there was a narrative
I saw last night on Fox News where they
kept pushing the idea that oh lives are
put at risk because accounts were
suppressed I guess it's the whole thing
it's weird so or we're like um
devalued in the algorithm and rank them
and whatnot so but really it's because
they violated the terms of service by
doing crazy bigoted xenophobic
transphobic things now the thing that I
find funny about this he goes oh you
know the Twitter and Facebook scandal he
brings up Facebook now if anyone doesn't
know this or if anyone remembers this or
doesn't remember rather uh there's
Cambridge analytica which goes back to
the 2016 election where this company
that worked with
the Trump campaign was able to illegally
access 87 million Facebook users
on how to you and then use that
information for the election right so
you mean you mean what they're accusing
Twitter of doing is that what you're
saying exactly okay and they're not and
here's the thing it's not even Facebook
it was a third party that got access to
stuff on Facebook and then sold it to
the Trump campaign it is insane it is
insanity that this guy literally could
be on bone of the week any week and it
would be for 15 different things is this
the quote true thing I don't know what
you would call this like so this is
stage on Twitter what does this mean
what does it mean he's saying that
because the FBI and justice department
were are pursuing him for the crimes
that he committed it's a police state
you know what I think he's actually
saying you know anything he's actually
saying I'm gonna go to prison and I
don't want to yeah I know I don't want
to go to prison I don't want to do it I
don't want to it's don't make me every
day on on true social he continues to
whine and project but also at the same
time admit to crimes you know he's like
look I took the documents it was totally
fine I'm the president and like wait you
said you wait on were they planted or
did you take them and they were yours
because you keep pushing this idea well
all they have all I have to say
um is Jack be nimble Jack be quick uh
everyone Donald Trump won the bone net
of the week that is not a surprise it is
not a surprise not a surprise but Gabe
Sanchez let's give him his do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
of the week of course he is why wouldn't
he be yeah why wouldn't he be why I mean
we're gonna we're gonna I look there's
probably a bonehead of the Year poll
that's gonna happen which sounds like
James Sanchez has some great stuff in
mind I've got some plans just wait up
but I wouldn't be surprised if Donald
Trump found his way on there and also
won but who knows it happens it happens
a lot of there's a lot of boneheads out
there there is and if you want to vote
for bonehead we go follow us at Tony
Michaels pod on Twitter you can vote
there every single week you can also
follow us on YouTube the Tony Michaels
podcast just put it in subscribe go to
the community tab on our YouTube channel
you will find the poll there and you
vote you decide every single Friday we
break it down here on detoni Michael's
podcast in the second hour and we put it
up on the Midas touch Network you get a
special clip from the bonetta league so
if you're online it's not subscribed
there if you're on our Channel right now
subscribe on our Channel you're not
going to want to miss the vote also
download code Gabe Sanchez you can
download every single bone of the week
on Sunday Apple Spotify Google your
favorite directory make sure when you're
subscribing to the Tony Michaels podcast
on your favorite directory leave us a
great review while you're there this is
my favorite my favorite this is it this
is my favorite segment of the week it's
Friday it's the end of the week it's
about the weekend and it's getting cold
out there so don't forget to go to store
not teach Tony michaels.com that's
store.beattonymichaels.com grab your the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty hoodie zip up
Hoodie sweater I ain't even getting on a
coffee mug Gabe Sanchez so go to store
not beat Tony michaels.com grab your
special merch there we thank you for all
your support
if you're on the Tony Michael's butt is
stick around we have a few announcements
and if and if not
that's the bone end of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week bone head of the
week
it's a great segment it's a great
segment I have to do a little more
editing now I don't know if I told you
that so at the end because it has the
soft transition now because I used to
just be able to cut it right now I gotta
but I'm doing more editing now bone end
of the week because yeah yeah we're just
we're just taking a clip of it and
posting on the minus touch Network yeah
so we you know we're just taking and I'm
sure today we'll probably take the
Donald Trump part
um oh yeah it talks about the documents
and the appeal and and all the other
crimes oh yeah this [ __ ] gay Miss
[ __ ] gay this [ __ ] game I really
are we do you think we're gonna get a
Christmas gift with Donald Trump
that's a good question Jack Smith do you
think he's going we got 15 days so like
everyone right on their Christmas list I
so so wish this happened it's okay I
mean I don't know it's honestly it's a
it's a fair question
I wanna I put myself in like a uh like a
70 30. like 70 I think it doesn't happen
right thirty percent twenty twenty two
thirty percent it could who knows
because Jack Smith as I said in the
Bonin Jack be nimble Jack be quick
I think we could get to a situation now
to be fair the select committee has not
released every single bit of their
evidence in their report to the
Department of Justice yet so there's
likely some that that that will happen
first before there will be indictments
also we know now now that he has not
appealed
um the special Master uh well the the
the knocking down of the special Master
of the 11th circuit and the special
Master is now wrapped up they're not
involved in the evidence anymore now the
doj is going to get full unfeathered
access to this
um evidence so I'm sure they're going to
want to comb through all that before
that happens and we know there's more
evidence overturning because Donald
Trump hired a special team to search
more areas and they found more documents
in a storage unit
thank you we gave you everything we gave
you everything that's everything we
don't have any more that's well I mean
if you're gonna understand check the
casket well I you know maybe they should
dig it up dig her up dig her uh man it's
kind of gross but you know and then it
is what it is I mean I used to use the
same phrase that they have lock him up
wake her up here's the thing what am I
supposed to do I what am I supposed to
do with The Narrative of the story
she dies the casket seems should be
really light it's just Azure a lot more
people carrying right casket he was
carrying boxes all over the country in
his plane boxes of paper are really
[ __ ] heavy I mean they're really
[ __ ] heavy yeah I don't know if you
carry around boxes of paper board
they're really heavy so I don't know I
don't know maybe maybe not maybe not
everybody
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page do not forget to subscribe
here on YouTube while you're here go
follow us on Twitter at the Tony
Michaels pod download every single
episode follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels hell go to Twitch download
that app and get it over there
and stay tuned Gabe's engines because I
promise you I am not going to stop
trying to figure out how we are going to
live stream from PornHub I am going to
be a porn star it's going to happen I
mean I'm not going to post news maybe I
will if people I don't know I I I don't
know of any podcasts that have I've seen
like I said I have fans I know friends
who are comedians who put up stand up
specials on PornHub I've seen movies on
PornHub I don't know if I've ever seen a
podcast that he's not a porn podcast we
are going to try to get on PornHub so
everyone let us know what you think
about getting on uh PornHub while you're
at it uh go to the Tony Mike Tony
michaels.line Tony Michaels dot live
leave us a tip there thank you for the
support everyone have a great weekend go
check out
store.dtonymichaels.com make sure to
grab your Grande Santos can go [ __ ]
himself and Liberty hoodies store at the
Tony michaels.com we appreciate all your
support have a great weekend
until Monday same time same place Surf's
Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon